GOLD REPORTS, ALMOST A YEAR AND
A HALF INTO BIDEN'S PRESIDENCY,
MANY PALESTINIANS SAY THEY SEE
LITTLE RESULTS.
>> FIVE YEARS AGO ON HIS LAST
VISIT TO THE WHITE HOUSE, THE
PALESTINIAN AUTHORITY PRESIDENT
MADE A RARE VENTURE INTO
ENGLISH.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, WITH YOU, WE
HAVE HOPE.
>> SEVERAL MONTHS LATER, THAT
PROEP PROVED TO HAVE BEEN
TERRIBLY MISPLACED.
>> IT IS TIME TO OFFICIALLY
RECOGNIZE JERUSALEM AS THE
CAPITAL OF ISRAEL.
>> UNDER DONALD TRUMP, U.S.
POLICY TILTED HEAVILY TOWARDS
ISRAEL.
THE PALESTINIAN POLITICAL OFFICE
IN WASHINGTON WAS CLOSED.
THE AMERICAN CONSULATE IN
JERUSALEM, WHICH SYMBOLIZED
U.S./PALESTINIAN RELATIONS, ALSO
CLOSED.
AND ALMOST ALL ECONOMIC AID TO
THE PALESTINIANS WAS SWITCHED
OFF.
SO WHEN JOE BIDEN WON THE
ELECTION, THERE WAS GREAT RELIEF
AMONG MANY IN THE PALESTINIAN
COMMUNITY.
BUT THAT RELIEF HAS LITTLE TO
SHOW IN TERMS OF ACTION.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
HIGHLIGHTS RENEWED FINANCING.
ABOUT HALF A BILLION DOLLARS,
MOSTLY ON SCHOOLS, HOSPITALS,
AND OTHER HUMANITARIAN AID
PROJECTS.
FURTHER $100 MILLION IS SET TO
BE ANNOUNCED ON THIS TRIP
INCLUDING SOME MONEY FOR
PALESTINIAN HOSPITALS IN EAST
JERUSALEM.
BUT POLITICALLY, THE WHITE HOUSE
SEEMS UNWILLING TO PRESSURE
ISRAEL OVER CONTINUED EXPANSION
OF WEST BANK SETTLEMENTS AND
WEAK IN THE FACE OF ISRAEL'S
RESISTANCE OVER PLANS TO REOPEN
THE CONSULATE IN JERUSALEM.
>> THE U.S. ADMINISTRATION HAS
BEEN TALKING WITH US ABOUT THESE
ISSUES FOR MORE THAN A YEAR, BUT
NOTHING HAS BEEN ACHIEVED.
EVEN SO, WE CONTINUE TO HOPE
THIS VISIT WILL PRODUCE SERIOUS
OUTCOMES THAT IT PROVIDES HOPE
AND A POLITICAL HORIZON.
>> BIDEN'S VISIT TO THE WEST
BANK WILL TAKE HIM NOT TO
RAMALLAH, THE HEADQUARTERS OF
THE PALESTINIAN AUTHORITY, BUT
TO BETHLEHEM A FEW MILES SOUTH
OF JERUSALEM.
WHERE THE PRESIDENT WILL FIND IT
HARD TO AVOID STARK REMINDERS OF
THE CONFLICT.
ONE ISSUE THAT WILL LIKELY BE
STARING PRESIDENT BIDEN RIGHT IN
THE FACE, THE KILLING OF SHU
RENE ABU OCLY, THE GIANT MURAL
OF THE JOURNALIST IS RIGHT ON
THE ROAD YOU TAKE AS YOU ENTER
BETHLEHEM.
FOR MANY HERE, THE U.S. RESPONSE
TO THE DEATH OF THE PALESTINIAN
AMERICAN REPORTER SHOT DEAD
WHILE COVERING A MILITARY
OPERATION HAS BEEN INADEQUATE
AND INDICATIVE, THEY BELIEVE, OF
THE U.S.'S UNWILLINGNESS TO
FORCE ISRAEL TO GET SERIOUS
ABOUT PEACE.
>> PUTTING AN END TO THIS
INJUSTICE, AN END TO THIS
IMPUNITY IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT
SHEDS LIGHT, IT CONTINUES TO
SHED LIGHT ON THE GREATER
PICTURE OF WHAT PALESTINIANS
CONTINUE TO ENDURE ON A DA